for decades new Brazilian presidents
made Argentina their first foreign trip
olsonaro rejected that tradition but his
successor Lula vasilva wants to go back
to the old ways and improve relations
between South America's Giants
we have a history that United us with
cultural things in common we have to
improve health care we have to organize
our energy developments we've spoken
about the benefit of Brazilian
electricity dear Lula this is your home
the Silvan Fernandez also discussed the
possibility of a common currency to
promote bilateral trade and reduce
Reliance on the US
Dollars
our finance ministers are currently
working each with his own economic team
to make us a proposal for foreign trade
and transactions between the two
countries that is done in a common
currency to be built after much debate
and many meetings president Lula da
Silva also came to Argentina to
participate in a Summit by a regional
block of Latin American and Caribbean
Nations Brazil left this block back in
2019 during the government of former
president jair bolsonaro because of the
presence of Cuba and Venezuela
the presence of Lula in this Summit also
shows that he's prioritizing rebuilding
the relationship with its Latin American
Neighbors
among those countries was Venezuela
president Nicola Maduro was also
expected in Buenos Aires but suspended
the trip the Venezuelan government said
there was a plan of aggression against
their leader
on Sunday Venezuelans living in Buenos
Aires said Argentina should not welcome
Nicola Maduro
[Applause]
Venezuela five years ago her daughter
had cancer and there were no medicines
to treat her
how can it be that a democratic country
will receive a tyrant a person that's
destroyed a country and has Allied
itself with Iranians and Russians I feel
horrible this is happening Brazil and
over 30 other countries will be part of
the summit happening in Buenos Aires on
Tuesday
its original block that will allow
countries in this part of the world to
discuss integration and how to best
solve the challenges they face